with the 2% growth of the EU the wind is  back in Europe sales said European  Commission President jean-claude Juncker  delivering an optimistic message at the  state of the EU address EU countries  import 65% of their gas consumption  mainly from Russia to secure their gas  supply they will have to help each other  in case of disruptions the EU s-- 28  member states are the world's second  largest and supplier lawmakers call for  setting up an arms control agency and  banning sales to non democratic  countries only 10% of total EU  greenhouse gas emissions are absorbed by  EU forests each year mep swat forests to  be better protected so they can absorb  more co2 emissions around 80 million  people in the EU have a disability  MEP s are working to make it easier for  them to access products and services  like phones cash dispensers and ticket  machines